le logo du tricolore tapissent les murs
de la chambre de métiers notamment à une
méthode et un milliard de ce canadien
mathieu claude un préposé aux
bénéficiaires lui en parle souvent au
coco furlan plus par mois il va
peut-être avoir une bonne saison j'ai
appris à connaître les résidences pour
les appeler par leur nom fait des
blagues et que je fais des patients qui
sont très atteints ici comme préposée
martin partage elle aussi beaucoup de
moments avec les résidants des maisons
d'à côté dans lanaudière ça fait joli
oui ça fait joli la résidence offre à
des gens lourdement handicapée comme
marie-france et mathieu une qualité de
vie comme nulle part ailleurs les 18
personnes qui au dessus de 18 personnes
qui sont policiers il n'existe que neuf
organismes communautaires au québec pour
ce genre de clientèle une 10e doit
ouvrir ses portes à joliette bientôt
mais le projet est compromis comme ce
contexte l'aude et objets de formes et
d'événements nos pensées nos listes
parce qu'on voit tour difficultés à le
culte sikh à l'écart de ça elle est au
taux de 7 8 pièces d'horreur la prime
que sont nos besoins faut garder son
peuple on pourra par des sangles de
katia ces trolls se comprenait tout le
monde va vouloir partir ici on voit la
fin éventuelle des mesures sanitaires
comme une épée de damoclès
alors que les négociations dans le
réseau public ont permis de trouver des
solutions on prie aime temporaire lié à
la coved le milieu communautaire a
l'impression d'être oubliés ces
choisissent de rester ici martine et
claude subiront une baisse salariale
quand les primes disparaîtront quand les
gens viennent chercher un peu
d'expérience et 6 pi qui vont cogner a
perdu 6000 ceci dit bah écoute et de
l'europe et d'expérience est ce qu'on
vous demande
c'est comme si le coût d'un service dans
un organisme communautaire pour va se
faire rare ab comparativement à ce qui
se fait dans les hoops ans les primes ça
nous prendrait vraiment une source
monétaire autres le gouvernement a
refusé notre demande d'entrevue en
affirmant que les discussions se
poursuivent sur la façon de maintenir
les services dans les milieux
communautaires d'hébergement qui sait
combien de temps ils pourront attendre
bonne journée en mer
on est ici véronique prince radio canada
québec